what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and today we're going to be
looking at the latest developments in
the demon Slayers story we had to wait
an extra week for this one but it was
definitely worth it so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you enjoy these demon
Surtur videos and want to keep them
coming
make sure to smash that like button and
share this video if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial hit
download vacation Bell or you will miss
future demon slayer videos for early
access to all of our reviews including
Demon Slayer you can follow our podcast
anime out pro audio on Spotify Apple
podcasts or wherever else you listen to
podcasts links in the description keep
in mind there will be manga spoilers
here I'm talking about the latest
chapter chapter 204 after all now
without further ado let's jump into it
we start off some nice colored pages of
cherry blossoms it's been three months
since tundra two overcame being the
demon king with the help of friendship
and tomorrow's medicine we're back at
the butterfly estate and we've got sent
into a Nino's case sleeping on tiger
Rose bed well he and mezu go stare out
at the window and talk seeing Xanten
Oski like this is adorable
the three amigos are all safe and sound
and getting some much-needed relaxation
time tendrils right eye has grown back
since he became a demon but it seems
clear that he cannot actually see from
it anymore still though he has a
remaining working eye and it lets him
enjoy the cherry blossoms which are in
full swing mezack oh super cute as she
comments on how pretty the cherry
blossoms are and we're told that the
days of fighting have ended it seems
that this chapter is going to be
dedicated to unwinding and closure after
that intense and long battle against
Mouzon and i'm glad that we're getting
at least a full chapter to process all
that's happened so that it can really
settle in fully we see a full color
spread of the characters that have died
and tundra and a Zuko remembering them
as usual doles that have passed away all
seem to be smiling and the living are
frowning as they mourn we're told that
the world is now without evil but so
many things have been lost in the
process and then we're told that we have
to live on as long as this body has a
tomorrow one of the great things about
works of art like Demon Slayer is that
although the story is unique the lessons
and emotions of the story can be applied
to our own
as well and we all know that there is
loss and suffering in real life the
manga is acknowledging that but also
emphasizing the importance of living on
until our own time to go comes the
lesson here is that you can fight for
what's right and win but it could
definitely cost a lot in the process and
the idea that the whole world is without
evil is a bit simplistic but hey it's a
shounen not a saimin and these
characters do deserve a happy ending
after all the losses they've endured
this chapter is called a world without
demons so it seems that for now at least
all demon threats have been taken care
of
along with Tundras I his arm the one
that he lost before he grew it back as a
demon doesn't work it's wrinkled like an
old man's arm and he can't even clench
his fist he can just move it up and down
I wasn't sure what approach to mangaka
would take with this obviously Nezu co
lost a lot of body parts when she was a
demon but she stayed fully recovered
when she became a human again I suppose
that because Tundra got these injuries
before he was fully a demon he couldn't
fully recover when he turned back to
human he kept the regrown parts but they
no longer worked this is probably the
right approach to take in my view since
it would have felt kind of cheap if he
just recovered completely
this way the sacrifice was very real and
it makes a defeat of Mouzon all the more
meaningful plus now he matches kono who
also lost vision in one eye yet another
clue that they are meant to be together
tons you know being his classic myself
turns a convo back to mezu KO and asks
if she's doing well after he hurt her as
a demon she's beaming when she says
she's totally fine she's clearly a great
sister and doesn't want tundra to worry
at all
he still feels bad that the damage that
he did will probably leave a scar and
he's sorry for what he did to everyone
else - and then we get some pretty fun
and unexpected words from Nessa ko
giving us a sense of her personality
this ko tells us that no one would care
about that and she says that if he
apologizes again she'll hit him someone
as cute as physical threatening to hit
someone is priceless Tangier accepts no
circles words and musical smiles saying
that she's glad her brother turned back
to human they talk about GU and how he
thought it was over when Meza ko was
bitten by demon ton judo and how it did
truly seem hopeless at times now they
can laugh and joke about it but they
don't take for
granted how lucky they are we get some
new important info here according to you
[ __ ] oh it was lucky that they had
shinobis medicine and that tons of bitna
Zucco first let's go ahead antibodies
since she recovered from being a demon
and that helped make Tundras recovery
possible as well Meza Co is pretty
confused about it but the important
thing for her and for us
is that Tundras ok in the flashback you
should a straight up says that both the
medicine and nerves goes blood and it's
antibodies were necessary for tundra to
return he emphasizes that it was crazy
good luck he also says that tundra
pretty much had the highest attitude of
any demon even higher than moves on and
ethical since he overcame the Sun in an
instant compared to Mexico who took much
longer so even though we didn't get to
see his full demon power it seems clear
that I was right to put him as the
strongest in my top 10 strongest demons
video link to that video in the
description by the way you should or
emphasizes that Tundra strong sense of
self made this possible - he was strong
willed enough to choose his friends and
principles over fear greed power and
immortality
I like that emphasis and we should
remember that it was more than just
medicine and antibodies which saved time
judo a strong will and principles are
something we can all cultivate just like
Tundra did and I like the fact that
something within all of our reach played
such a crucial role rather than just
super powers ushido out of character
smiles and praises tons you know pendra
smoove to tears and feels awkward but
tries to emphasize the importance of his
friends - you should although quickly
goes back to usual he puts on the mask
of a jerky where sometimes over his kind
heart and calls ton showed the worst and
says he doesn't want to see his face
anymore before he leaves you shoulda
takes tomorrow's demon cat one of the
things he has to remember her by and
gives tundra a sincere take care as he's
going tundra begs him not to die and
says that he's the only one who can
remember tomorrow forever you should
have done leaves without saying a word
and man that's deep and powerful you
should have loved Tommy or more than
anyone else and when you lose someone
you love that much tundra knows it can
lead people into dark places so he gives
you shadow a noble purpose to keep on
living that is tied to
lobotomy oh I'm pretty sure that
psychologist Viktor Frankl spoke
similarly to a man who lost his wife and
if you've watched in John wick movies
you know that that's what keeps him
going - he lives on so he can keep
remembering his wife who tragically
passed away he also had a dog to
remember her by and taking care of him
helped him as well ushido here has
cameos cat and I'm sure he'll also
follow this advice and live on so that
he can remember Tamayo it's a short
exchange but it's very powerful
nonetheless then tundra jumps back to
topic of view and the shape of Gil's
body mezu Koecher said that he's alright
and that he's at Kiryas we jumped at a
meeting between the two remaining
pillars Gihon son of me and kiria and
his sisters this appears to be their
final meeting ever we're told that the
demons have finally been destroyed and
that the demon hunters will finally be
disbanded it's a bittersweet moment
they've sacrificed so much and they
probably won't spend as much time
together anymore but the world is
finally a safer place cutie and his
sisters bow and sincerely thank the two
pillars now that they stopped moves on
the oubli Isshiki family should no
longer be cursed with early deaths do
you aunts enemy don't want their leader
to bow to them but it goes to show how
much this all means to the Hui Isshiki
family who struggled so long to stop
Mouzon gu tells Correa who despite his
responsibility is still only a little
kid that his fathers and forefathers
would be proud of him and finally now
that the Moose on business is over kiria
can finally drop all of those
responsibilities and be a kid for the
first time he cries while thanking you
for his kind words we've then jumped to
tengan Tsui the former sound pillar and
his wives who visit ton Judah they know
he's going home after he finishes
recuperating tomorrow and they invite
him to come by their house when he's up
for it
I'm really glad that they'll be
maintaining these relationships after
all said and done even cure Jordan
Goku's brother and dad make an
appearance remember at one point the
father was not so cool with kanjiru the
chosen one of the superior breath style
he was rude to him and he regrets it he
thanks Tonto for fighting with Kyoto
roseguard and says that Kuro would be
happy
tundra sure said that he is
the one who should be thanking Kuro
since his words consoled him countless
times and it's totally true although a
tengoku passed on early he was amazing
and his example helped tundra and the
rest keep going until they succeeded he
set all of our hearts ablaze and I will
always consider Kyoto one of my favorite
characters besides who wakes up as the
sword smiths and more demon center
members show up and filled a doorway
these guys come practically every single
day and this really shows how many
connections tons on his friends have
major in this journey you wouldn't even
remember everyone if you weren't
thinking about it but this chapter fits
them all in so that we really do get a
fulfilling sense of closure here and we
can remember all the different
adventures Tundra has been on when we
see all these different groups of people
as I need to screams the room is full
Kendra is the auntie moves on since the
demon king of pop was left all alone in
the darkness while Tundra is surrounded
by a bright and warm atmosphere with
more loving people around him than you
can even count because he's helped
others instead of acting selfishly all
the time like moves on he's rewarded
many times over eNOS case sneaks out
hilariously as he works his way
animal-like through people's feet he
sneaks into the kitchen and starts
eating but Allie is not having it in
those case says he didn't eat through a
mouthful of food he's also impressed
that oh you noticed him thinking that
she's actually stronger more skilled
than he thought how he gives eNOS Kay
his own plate saying he can eat from
there anytime but not to steal anyone
else's we can see that eNOS key is
pretty touched and impressed by Allie
and the food she gave him and just as a
new relationship may be blossoming
between them we jump to Canal looking at
a cherry blossom tree hundred joins her
so clearly the mangaka keeps pushing
this ship along we see that her right
eye just like can Joe's right eye
doesn't work but with their working eyes
they enjoy the view of the cherry
blossom tree up close I actually really
like the story we get here about the
fact that the cherry blossom tree was
planted by the very first swordsman who
used a breath of flower style very cool
and this swordsman named a tree certain
victory and here it is still growing
after the demon slayers have achieved
victory very cool flower swordsman they
cool pun drew is worried about how badly
he heard Cano
but she assures him that she can see and
her wound is all better we figure out
that son of me dropped by and left eager
to a snake the best snake in anime with
Cano I didn't see Kunal getting the
snake coming but it's nice that it
worked out that way we definitely don't
want Kabuto motto being lonely as all
three are getting along swimmingly we
jump to sodomy and a Zuko now there's
some real unresolved stuff between these
two sodomy was a huge jerk who hurt our
precious des ago and tried to kill her
obviously we now know that he did that
because of his own tragic backstory but
he still never had that redeeming moment
with Nezzer ko
after such horrible behavior neza ko
says hello she's clearly not harboring
any resentment she smiles and inquires
about his injuries he's feeling kind of
awkward but Mexico is beaming glad that
he's alright although it's hard for him
he apologizes for everything including
the fact that he slept through the moves
on fight as the circle makes it clear
that there's nothing to apologize for
her expression makes him think of his
lower brother ganya who passed away in
the fight against Coco Chabot we get a
sincere head pat and we see the tough
usually angry son of me smile which is
really touching I must say he leaves
mezco is flustered after the head
padding and xeni too is flipping out at
their seeing this it's perfect that they
followed up that touching moment with
Xanadu being jealous and overprotective
of mezu ko this chapter has a nice
combination of humor and genuinely
touching moments and it seems after this
chapter that all three amigos have girls
that they shared special moments with in
this chapter finally no Zuko and Tanja
are reunited with you and sukwon ji
another touching moment that we've all
been waiting for these guys took a shot
on our two protagonists before they met
the others they helped them when things
seemed hopeless and even vowed to take
their own lives if nezu ko as a demon
killed a human and now after everything
they're reunited with the two people
they helped save after all that's
happened they can finally laugh hug and
be carefree together however it's not
just about the people who made it and
the mangaka wants to make it clear that
a lot of people died fighting bows on
the graves seem endless
and finally nosce decides to throw the
flowers
on them sloppily since it's already dark
out obviously the end wouldn't be
complete until Nezha co and tundra
returned back home like they kept saying
they were gonna do and I'm very happy to
see in those cans I hate SU going with
them
even cited to senses with them in the
form of his ashes he knows k hilariously
wonders if the ashes can be eaten in
this line just made me realize that he
knows k and rock from tower of God
definitely have the same energy we see
sub you know who was the neighbor that
let hundred or sleep at his house so
that he wouldn't be attacked by demons
during the night he hugged tundra
Natsuko and evens any two gets in on
some hug action as he no ski awkwardly
touches the man's back with one finger
not knowing what to do man I'm really
gonna miss you knows K they go back to
the house pay their respects to their
family members who have passed on and
started cleaning up the old place
he knows K cannonballs into a small bath
while sided to his bathing and then we
see the four sharing a meal happily it
is a perfect scene and the long empty
house is now full with life warmth and
laughter again that could be the end
right there and a satisfying end it
would be but we get a bit more we see a
modern landscape and then we're told
time goes by it's the modern era next
issue Center color with 24 pages and
quote and wow that's pretty crazy I did
not expect this but it seems like we are
having a time skip and we're going to
have twenty four pages of the time skip
in the next chapter there's been talk
that the demon Surtur manga is supposed
to end in May so that might be the last
chapter but it could also be the
beginning of a sequel or spin-off like
we saw with other popular series I'm
extremely excited to see what's gonna
happen next and let me know what you
expect to see in this Timescape chapter
I'm glad we're not done yet even though
I do feel like this chapter did a great
job of giving us closure everything
wrapped up very nicely at the very least
even if we don't get a sequel we'll
probably find out if the ships I've been
talking about sailed or not in the next
chapter it's definitely looking like we
might get a demon slayer series set in
modern times which could be interesting
kind of like JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
keeps things fresh by similarly jumping
forward in time with each part I'm
holding out hope but this chapter was
pretty much the end of Demon Slayer as
we know it and I'm so thankful that I
could enjoy it with you every week like
this sharing my experience with a space
fan has made it even more enjoyable than
it would have been if I read it alone so
thank you for checking in every week and
hanging out and that is it for today's
review if you enjoyed this review make
sure to smash that like button share
this video I've been reviewing this
series every week for a while now and
it's really become a big part of my life
I'm gonna miss the manga if it
completely ends well we have the anime
film to look forward to this year and
the animation of so many epic moments
I'll still be making Dimas air videos so
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell because you
will miss future demon center videos if
you don't and remember that you can get
early access to all of our reviews
including Demon Slayer by following our
anime opera audio podcast
links in the description lastly the
YouTube ad rates have significantly
dropped recently so the help and support
we're getting from our anime up for
patrons is now more important than ever
a very special thank you goes to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank the legend acknowledged by Lord
Twigg Oh himself Efrain a and the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Steven and Radha
Aloha autumn the world stealers Tyson
Kirino acquire respect potato fuh
Jonathan King deci d brandon of aisles
and emperor otaku and our pro hero to
your patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius Anatole Kazansky angel Cruz I
Sparky 65 cricket XP Ted no Ted Joe
Stanton very Gucci Alicia actor animal
69 jessica calif on he no commie and
water
Bonnie parks is OD r12 wrath oh and a
Ora Tian Wong Mitch loves anime and JCCC
waka thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
an Emir or and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to a
private patient only discord where we
talked about anime
life and of course dank memes so check
out patreon.com/crashcourse
link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]